PHILADELPHIA EAGLES?
DROP ME A LINE ON TWITTER
@BretBaier.
USE THE HASHTAG #SpecialReport
OR ON FACEBOOK AT
Facebook.com/BretBaierSR.
PAUL MANAFORT IS AWAITING TRIAL
ON SERIOUS CRIMINAL CHARGES.
NOW HE'S BEING ACCUSED OF TRYING
TO INFLUENCE POTENTIAL
WITNESSES.
THIS HAPPENS AS LAWMAKERS LEARN
MORE ABOUT TWO OF THE BIGGEST
TOPICS IN WASHINGTON THESE DAYS.
CHIEF INTELLIGENCE CORRESPONDENT
CATHERINE HERRIDGE HAS THE
REPORT.
>> THE FBI'S ESPIONAGE CHIEF
WITH DIRECT KNOWLEDGE OF THE
CLINTON EMAIL AND RUSSIAN
INVESTIGATIONS TESTIFIED FOR THE
FIRST TIME BEHIND CLOSED DOORS
FOR HOUSE INVESTIGATORS.
FORMER NUMBER TWO FBI AGENT
PETER STRZOK WAS A CENTRAL
PLAYER IN THE CLINTON EMAIL
PROBE AND LATER REMOVED FROM THE
RUSSIA CASE FOR ANTI-TRUMP BIAS.
BASED ON TESTIMONY AND
DOCUMENTS, ONE REPUBLICAN SAID
PETER STRZOK APPEARED TO BE
RUNNING THE SHOW.
>> THE TEXT MESSAGES AND EMAILS
PRODUCED TO THE OVERSIGHT AND
JUDICIARY COMMITTEES.
WHILE TECHNICALLY THAT MAY HAVE
BEEN A PRESTEP CALL, I THINK IT
WAS MORE PETER STRZOK TURBINE.
>> SAYING THAT THE TESTIMONY WAS
TO REPORT, DIRECT, AND THAT HE
INTERVENED ONCE THE EXTRAMARITAL
AFFAIR BETWEEN STRZOK AND LISA
PAGE WAS KNOWN.
>> HE WAS A SUPERVISOR.
I THINK THAT HE TOOK THE
APPROPRIATE ACTIONS ONCE HE
FOUND OUT ABOUT THE NATURE OF
THE RELATIONSHIP.
>> REPUBLICANS WANT MORE
INFORMATION ABOUT THE ALLEGED
CONVENTIONAL HUMAN SOURCE THAT
CONTACTED FROM CAMPAIGN AIDES.
HE REALLY TRAVELED OVERSEAS.
LAWMAKERS PRESSED HIM ON ME TRIP
TO LONDON AND WHETHER IT WAS
CONNECTED TO THE RUSSIAN PROBE
THAT STRZOK LAUNCHED TWO MONTHS
LATER.
>> THAT'S CONFIDENTIAL AND I
CAN'T SPEAK TO IT.
PRESTEP AND JAMES COMEY AND
OTHERS ARE THE SUBJECT OF A
LONG-AWAITED INSPECTOR GENERAL'S
REPORT INTO A FIERCE HANDLING OF
THE CLINTON EMAILS.
WITH CONGRESSIONAL COMMITTEES IN
A HOLDING PATTERN WAITING FOR
THE REPORT TO DROP ANY DAY, ON
TWITTER THE PRESIDENT QUESTIONED
"WHAT IS TAKING SO LONG ON
CROOKED HILLARY AND SLIPPERY
JAMES COMEY," ADDING "I HOPE THE
REPORT IS NOT BEEN CHANGED AND
MADE WEAKER."
SPECIAL COUNSEL ALLEGED PAUL
MANAFORT TRY TO TAMPER WITH
POTENTIAL WITNESSES TO STATE
THEIR TESTIMONY AND THE MONEY
LAUNDERING AND TAX FRAUD
PROSECUTION.
IN A STATEMENT, A SPOKESMAN SAID
"MR. MANAFORT IS INNOCENT AND
NOTHING ABOUT THIS LATEST
ALLEGATION CHANGE THEIR DEFENSE.
WE WILL DO OUR TALKING IN
COURT."
SPECIAL POSSIBLY MANAFORT MY
LITTLE BAIL >> PAUL MANAFORT
OUGHT TO BE JAILED, MOST
LIKELY I THINK SHOULD FACE SERIO
LIKELY I THINK SHOULD FACE SERIS
LIKELY I THINK SHOULD FACE SERIC
LIKELY I THINK SHOULD FACE SERII
LIKELY I THINK SHOULD FACE SERIA
LIKELY I THINK SHOULD FACE SERIL
PENALTIES FOR WITNESS TAMPERING.
>> WITHIN THE LAST MINUTES, SIX
AND A HALF HOURS OF CLOSED-DOOR
TESTIMONY HAS COMPLETED.
ONE LLAMA CARE DESCRIBED BILL
PRIESTAP AS EXTREMELY
COOPERATIVE, ADDING BASED
ON THE LATEST INFORMATION,
DOCUMENTS, TESTIMONY AND OTHER
RECORDS, IT SEEMS CLEAR TO THEM
NOW THAT FBI AGENT PETER STRZOK
PLAYED A MUCH GREATER ROLE THAN
PREVIOUSLY KNOWN IN THE CLINTON
EMAIL AND RUSSIAN
INVESTIGATIONS.
THEY EMPHASIZED A GREATER ROLE
THAN WHAT WAS INDICATED IN THE